[Musique]
épaules merci merci pour ce cadeau
somptueux maintenant si bien équipé il
va bien aller je fais partie de la
maison bocuse est aujourd'hui le travail
c'est facile c'est un poireau pomme de
terre un soupe de nos grands mères
oui c'est à dire il faut quelques
poireaux quelques pommes de terre et un
peu de beurre et surtout attention l'eau
parce que l'eau est très difficile pour
un potage bien souvent il faut avoir
l'eau d'une source ou dullin puis à
bruay ou alors si on n'a pas d'eau on
peut avoir une eau minérale parce que
les autres villes bien souvent on du
chlore et fait un très mauvais potage
entre ma tâche pour important salo mélo
c'est très important
très bien alors là j'ai du travail je
vais juger mais attend la ferme a
commencé à continuer le menu la
apprendre à une volaille une volaille de
bresse qu'on va faire la crème houllier
avec du vin blanc et comme dessert on
fera des pommes en l'air des pommes en
l'air au four c'est à dire c'est des
pommes qui sont cuites avec du sucre du
bord arrosez de vin blanc et demi dans
le four c'est délicieux eh bien je pense
qu'on va attaquer parfaire le potage et
qu'est ce qu'on boit avec tout ça et
bien on va voir un apremont c'est-à-dire
un vin de savoie c'est un petit vin
léger et la promo est un vin très
merveilleux surtout je pense avec le
poulet à la crème pour faire les
poireaux il ya une question de la ville
écolo pour laver la wiz assez
correctement il faut défendre assez loin
et les laver dans de l'eau chaude parce
que quand on lave dans de l'eau chaude
ça amélie un peu les fait vibrer et la
terre s'en va beaucoup mieux alors vous
allez me laver les poireaux 8 laval à la
source et la mlv dans la gamelle via
chèque est là maintenant on a été chez
les pommes de terre ayant un lien secret
pour les pommes de terre
il faut jamais laver les pommes de terre
après il faut les laver avant donc ses
pommes de terre ont été lavés parce que
nos pommes de terre qu'a passées dans
l'eau elle perd sa fécule et les moins
bonnes
donc on épluche les pommes de terre
alors il faut une pomme de terre jaune
est en général la pomme de terre qui va
le mieux pour ce potage c'est la branche
tout comme terre assez charnues et de
bon goût
donc on n'est plus chez pomme de terre
voyez donc elles sont pas sérieuses
puisqu'elles ont été lavés à bord
vous savez une pomme de terre qui est
bien bien laver et bien brossé et bien
dans un potage nous y laisser la peau et
bien c'est délicieux bon moi j'ai
presque fini ça y est et bien pas moi
rapport vont alors écoutez moi vous
allez prime éplucher les pommes de terre
la wii voilà c'est pour l'instant moi je
m'en vais couper les poires au betis
commence voilà les preuves sont là ça
c'est rien ça me touche et les donc pour
couper les poireaux c'est facile vous
coupe les poireaux le coupon 4 et ayant
les mêmes le plus fin possible et on
laisse un peu de vert parce que je pense
que levet avec un potage c'est délicieux
ça colore week-end mais tellement voile
à l'école henri et vous savez aucun bon
potage pas aux pommes soient bons il
doit cuire en tout 15 minutes à grand
bouillon une minute de plus pas couverts
et par couvert est jamais trop mouillé
c'est dit avec un potage doit être
mouillé exactement jouent trop ce qu'il
faut alors je peux pas donner l'élite
des quantités bien pour catherine et
combien de personnes pour six couverts
site où il faut à peu près 350 g de
pommes de terre
200 g de poireaux avec le vert bien
laver à l'eau chaude parce que vous avez
vu maintenant il est en plus un brin de
terre et puis faut un litre d'eau bah
c'est pas moi j'ai ramassé tout à
l'heure ils se mirent la vraie voilà
alors vous savez le froid au pied même à
ses fins voilà et on va couper les
pommes de terre
alors là bien secret pour les poireaux
on va mettre la 4e sur le feu et on va
la mettre avec du beurre c'est à dire
qu'on va faire revenir les poireaux dans
le beurre les saints qui colore c'est à
dire que les poires ou soit tombé au
beurre ça c'est très important
tombé au bord qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est bien qu'ils soient colotti soit
cuit enfin tomber dans le beurre 100
écolo et c'est à dire suer dans le
beurre vous faire voir à son goût et
habib sy
ils n'ont pas eu d'ennuis et vous savez
là ça c'était le potage préféré de
monsieur point tous les soirs on dirait
un porc aux pommes
parce que je crois c'est un délicieux
potages dans le fond ça s'appelle le
potage parisien en termes de cuisine on
la voit là une au poireau voiliers sont
ils sont ciselés sans être 6 les
trophées on prend une une casserole dans
cette casserole
on y met du beurre ben voyons mais à peu
près 100 g de beurre 1 oui 150 pour
capter sa voix là et on met là en plein
feu c'est dans les pommes de terre les
plans beauté je m'en vais m'en occuper
je me vais les couper non non vous allez
procéder à me faire revenir les poireaux
lâchant qui brûle
voilà donc les poireaux vont revenir
dans le beurre avec une fourchette en
cuillère en bois
la spatule oui moi je joue cement voilà
et moi je m'en vais vous est mince et
les pommes de terre dans les pays notés
'aaa' c'est pareil on les est mince
qu'on peut pas trop gros mais pas trop
fine non plus alors à la langue de terre
c'est très fort ça va très bien
ça va ça reviendra bien il faut bien
faire revenir un bien su est bien ce qu
est alors les pommes de terre vont
bientôt être prête
voilà les 15 minutes temps pour enfin
dès que ça bout 15 minutes c'est la
qualité de ce potage
il faut qu'il soit très vite puis envoyé
les pommes de terre son temps pour la
bonne raison qu'elles n'ont pas traîné
dans l'eau une pomme de terre qui passe
une nuit dans l'eau c'est pas possible
c'est immangeable le qualité d'un gratin
de pommes de terre la qualité d'une
pomme de terre c'est ne pas être passée
dans l'eau toujours laver avec l'art je
l'avais avec la pauvre et un jour vous
essayerez et de faire un potage en
épluchant seulement une pomme ter sur 2
le relais c'est la pop au flottage vous
verrez c'est délicieux c'est une bonne
idée
bon les poireaux sont presque revenus
live et bien maintenant on va faire on
va ces remous y est en temps on va faire
revenir les pommes de terre voilà
et maintenant on va salle et le sel a
pour but de faire cracher un peu l'eau
ca sera que meilleur et vous avez un
potage ou qu'ils soient bons ou sa salle
du premier coup
la première fois et il faut à peu près
15 g de sel pour un litre d'eau alors
moi j'ai l'habitude qu'ingram ça y est
alors ça revient de passer deux ans et
voilà vous faites bien revenir ça et ça
yaya plus d'heures le beurre et compte
encore un petit peu revenir les pouvoirs
bien ciblées et moi je reviens vous
mouiller de leeds au alors l'eau c'est
bien important
fiona l'eau du puits si on ajoute source
est merveilleux d'ailleurs à paris à une
fontaine je ne sais pas quelle place est
laid mais une fontaine où il ya de
l'autre sourit merveilleuse ira les
chercher un potage aller chercher
l'autre jour pour faire un potage vous
verrez c'est merveilleux alors on va
mouiller alors voilà alors un jour
quatre personnes
aussi si j'avais 10 6 1 litres pour 6
voix là et ça fait 1 car maintenant les
oui on prend la montre dans quinze
minutes c'est bon faut vider un poulet
on commence à couper les petits ailerons
voilà poste bien souvent les ménagères
ne sortent pas habiter un poulet il
coupe et d'ailleurs alors là vous avez
appris déjà pour la dinde sur lorenzo à
pâtisserie ou un vélo mais voilà on
coupe les pattes aussi à la haye
maintenant on va pouvoir vider la
volaille alors on vit de la volaille on
commence à enlever l'arrière et ont des
tâches les les poumons par en hausse à
dire les poumons et jabot voyez donc le
jabot là où il ya les craint la grèce la
grèce et les graines là vous passez
votre doigt pour bien décoller les
poumons le long des côtes
voilà c'est bien décoller vous avez les
rythmes plus rien à bout d'aurier mais
plus chez un oignon là pendant ce temps
à matane et sabu pas les 20 minutes et
on tranche surveille du coin de l'oeil
très bien mais plus celle échalotes la
nunuche et la carotte tendance neutre la
volaille
voilà et l'on là pour vider bien voilà
il dans les bars on va avoir donc le
foie les poumons a tout à voir vous
savez avec le choix de volaille là on
avait fait un gâteau de foies de
volaille ça c'est important
voilà alors donc on a tout ici les
pâtres le cours et maintenant je veux
faire voir pour le découper alors pour
le découpage c'est très facile on va le
découper en 8 pour le découper en 8 la
coupe tout est un peu grand mais salah
l'échalote mansat encore s'il n'avait
pas envoyé vous prenez la cuisse
beaucoup que la cuisse et vous marquez
la cuisse très loin jusqu'au bout vous
détacher un petit peu et c'est bon donc
voyez vous avez une cuisse et bien
détaché de la carcasse cette mail groupé
l'aileron là et là vous prenez les ailes
et vous marquez bien là le plus loin
possible
voilà donc vous avez une aile et bien
découpé loyer voilà l'autre cuisse
l'oignon et l'ail l'oignon et l'ail et
vous débouchez la carotte plus elle pas
d'envoyer on a nos poulets qui est
découpé un autre carcasse donc les deux
elles sont faites là le bret cher va
couper le bois celle là on coupe le
bréchet en deux voilà ça c'est vrai ou
pas deux oui si vous voulez couver leurs
oeufs on va mettre la carcasse parce
qu'en même temps on va faire comme une
ménagère peur une ménagère elle n'a pas
de fond blanc est la plume à rien donc
on procède comme une ménagère 1.7.2
cuisinier n'a pas voilà qui n'a pas de
réserve ont fait exactement comme si on
était dans la cuisine on a coupé les
cuisses en deux beaucoup plus les
cuissons de voilà on va couper c'est
plus la une boule dai nghia voilà il
coûts en maintenant on va attaquer la
voyez la crème heures donc on met du
beurre dans la casserole
combien combien 100 g de beurre et on
sale les morceaux de volaille surtaxés
doivent jamais au cours de la crise or
donc normalement un plat bien fait il
est sale et du la première fois un mur
touche plus comme un potage ailleurs je
vous ai jamais douté quand un potager en
salle et après il n'a jamais le même
goût
oui c'est vrai moi j'aime tellement boot
et moi jusqu'au bout j'ai justice
les coupes de choc côté parce que c'est
plus facile à manger vous faire très
attention qu'on fait parce qu'il est
pour les professionnels qui regardent et
utilisent ou là c'est pas ça très
attention vous avez eu des réflexions
alors donc on commence à faire marcher
les rouges c'est à dire les rouges de
volaille c'est à dire les groupes cuisse
et les cuisses alors on met le bord et
là le potage nous voilà la volaille va
revenir on va la faire suer c'est à dire
si on fait une volaille ça y est un
petit peu pour mais les blancs la
carcasse et on met retour à faire
revenir notre live le potage bout
maintenant qu'ils vont bon train et on
remue vos parties la tâche vous voyez
les mouiller sur ce qu'il faut on écume
pas parce que si on écume c'est le
beurre qui s'en va à bord sera donc je
préfère qu'il reste un peu des cultes et
que bear reste avec voilà et là on fait
revenir les morceaux de volaille les
morceaux de volaille retrouve maintenant
le titane la masse et les cuillères m
lalanne tôt hier donc la voie là il
revient le côté il faut la faire colorer
la faire suer c'est à dire c'est ce qui
va donner les sucres et ça va être très
agréable
voilà voilà allez olla le potage a
commencé à bouillir et du mans je la
commence à puer bouillir on peut goûter
et je pense que dans nos têtes on va
envoyer là moi j'ai mis la carcasse j'ai
mis la carcasse j'aime il est cuit
j'ai pas mis les pas parce que les
pattes qui aurait fallu les ébouillanter
pour enlever la peau parce que si on met
les pattes comme ça les goûts et dégoûts
du goût de barros et les volailles
d'hommes se débarrasser d'un boulet gym
et allonge vous avez dit gousses d'ail
en chemise pas épluché à hosni en
chemise pendant que quand les volailles
revenus jumelles échalotes puis mais
l'oignon et j'ai fait un petit bouquet
garni et dans le bouquet garni un peu de
persil il ya un petit peu de laurier un
petit peu de céleri un petit peu de
temps de l'attention voilà trois ans
veut voilà donc la volaille et là elle
va bon train mais une grosse différence
entre la gousse d'ail ans n'a pas du
tout le même goût c'est à dire ça
parfume semble donner le goût d'ail et
vous savez après on enlève la blague de
la chemise on les écrase et on lit la
crème avec le jaune d'oeuf et la purée
de volaille
voilà très bien bon voilà donc la
volaille revenus voyez les colorés sans
être trop coloré voilà et maintenant je
mens et mouiller un peu de vin blanc
et comme dans un ménage d'un peu d'eau à
vous les mains porter l'eau voilà
dans la volaille était sale et la
volaille et et poivrez elle était
revenue il ya les rognons il ya les
l'oignon il ya le bouquet garni il ya
l'échalote et l'ail en chemise elle
était saler poivrer
donc je mouille à peu près d'un quart de
vin blanc voilà vous avez vous pouvez
faire exactement une blanquette de veau
1 la même chose avant élargie et de
l'eau parce que une ménagère n'a pas de
fond blanc et s'il n'a pas de fond blanc
elle prend de l'eau et du moment qu'elle
a mis les carcasses dedans ça va faire
le fond blanc alors là c'est qu'il
laisserait de la caisse que celle
comblant le fond blanc c'est un show qui
est fait avec des abattis de volaille
qui est préparé à l'avancé mais moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord
une cuisine minutes comme ça c'est aussi
agréable par contre deux villes me
prévoir le couvert pour cette casserole
il encore pas venu à ben non j'ai rien
prendre une tout autre chose
c'est le côté 1 prévoit qu'on va bien
maintenant le passage il a encore faim
minutes à cuire
on va laisser cuire la volaille là
pendant 20 minutes
oui on reviendra demain et on reviendra
dans 20 minutes
c'est celui-là voilà et là maintenant on
laisse cuire donc bien là là paul bocuse
bon tout ça a été si vite vous avez vous
demandé quelques précisions pour le
poulet poulain vous avez mis les
meilleurs morceaux de la carcasse a
besoin de te dire qu'en même temps on a
cuit la volaille la carcasse tout en
même temps c'est à dire que ça fait un
saut carotte l'oignon l'ail en chemise
le bouquet garni un quart de vin blanc
de l'eau du puits
ou alors si on n'a pas l'eau du puits
une eau minérale sans chlore oui et on
laisse cuire à peu près 20 minutes mais
voilà maintenant mais pas les abats non
je vois riel fois je les gardais on
aurait pu mettre le gésier bon eh les
gars le fois j'aime bien garder pour
faire un gâteau de foies de volaille
waller une chose qui est merveilleux
c'est le faire sauter à la poêle
oui une fois qu'il sautait à square le h
est légèrement il mettait dans une sauce
salade
surtout si c'est de la laitue une laitue
au sein de l'aïe c'est merveilleux
d'ailleurs pour manger qu'un poulet
modèle envie d'avancer un prêt donc vous
voyez le potage maintenant il a quinze
minutes et les cuisses à gaza lors du
moment qu'il est cuit un coup de fouet
dedans c'est à dire on ne passe pas du
moment que tout a été coupée et vous
savez ce qu'ils donnent bon goût d'être
un potage comme ça et bien se dire
ajouté
un peu de crème c'est à dire de la crème
qui va pas vous dire on va en mettre à
peu près 100 g de crème
voilà et et vous servez tout de suite on
fouette un petit peu voilà et en serre
et on serre et vous pouvez vous pouvez
le servir avec des petits croûtons de
pain et du gruyère alors envoyé le
potage il est lié pour cette un jour
c'est d'une certaine façon il n'y a pas
eu trop d'eau vous pouvez le goûter je
pense pas qu'il y aura un remettre de
sel attention c'est chaud maintenant ça
y est notre soupe
8 voilà alors un petit coup de fouet
dans un petit coup de fouet et lagoon et
on va s'occuper de décanter la volaille
c'est à dire d'enlever la volaille en
bon eh bien s'il fallait bien j'ai
tablier sur les raisons moi je m'en vais
décanter la volaille c'est à dire jean
lève tout les bons morceaux
le groupe puisse les solidays l'ale
voilà que les bons morceaux
oui je laisse sa carcasse de da manha
voix lascive et parfaite ça va servir
bon on va enlever les petits oignons
compte remettre dedans c'est bon les
aiderons je prends une cuillère vous
êtes vous y attendez voir des ailerons
ici ces petits oignons parce que c'est
bon vous avez bien mis dans maintenant
j'écrase des blues avec dedans j'avais
dit trajet d'un j'écrase l'oignon qui
reste la carotte c'est à dire tout ça
donne bon goût la volaille et la
volaille et les latins et maintenant on
va mouiller sa à la crème c'est à dire
que vont bien on va en mettre un presque
1 400 grammes quoi envoyer mais on va
faire cuire la crème la wii c'est
gourmand ça demande beaucoup à l'envoyé
de la crème double 1 on dit que la crème
double la crème épaisse ne joue pas mais
voyez c'est une erreur vous bien alors
là on va faire cuire un petit peu cette
crème dans les carcasses la voyez un
voyage avait des séquelles et les bas
morceaux très bon morceau les coûts là
et on va laisser cuire ça un peu près
cinq minutes c'est à dire avec les
cartes maîtresses ah oui oui à un bon
feu 1
voilà on va il fait bouillir voilà dans
la volaille et la halle à temps on va
découvrir un petit peu pour pas quel
club le froid voilà c'est là on va faire
bouillir ça et maintenant on va préparer
une liaison une maison au jour neuf
alors très facile pour faire la liaison
au jaune d'oeuf
on casse l'ofs on enlève le blanc et on
est à peu près deux jaunes pour un demi
litre de liquide
il va y avoir un peu point de me dit
voilà on avait les deux jaunes qui sont
là et pour pouvoir bien les mélanger
avec le restant de la crème on va les
battre avec un tout petit peu de crème
de da est toujours dedans un petit peu
de poivre du moulin
parce que le poivre du moulin me au
dernier moment dans une sauce c'est une
chose qui est très agréable
il faut toujours mettre du poids mouche
eu faim ou est ce un écrit talal envoyé
la sauce bout ça fait à peu près dix
minutes que ça cuit
voilà va être juste liés au moment et on
va lier tout ça avec les quartiers de
les voir voilà ça vous commencez à baal
battre un peu battle en titre avec la
fourchette avec la pochette
donc le coup on peut mettre même le
cours est le coup c'est toujours une
chose j'étais toujours les amateurs de
moyens beaucoup
voilà voilà ça vous alors là il est
écrasé l'oignon est écrasée et voiliers
pour lui un phénomène le sud des viandes
avec cette crème double c'est déjà
presque liés comme il faut aurait vu la
volaille la bouillie à peu près dans le
vin blanc dans l'eau avec les oignons
les carcasses abri à peu près 20 minutes
il faut à peu près 20 minutes pour une
volaille pour envoyer votre sauce soul
il a doucement ça beau bon ben ça va on
va bouillir sa taille s à bout et là
maintenant on va lier au journal envoyée
à ya peu près 1 à peu près 8 10 minutes
que ça bout et ont valu aux ornements
attention sur polyjoule à il faut faire
très attention - c'est à dire que votre
sauce nous on est enfin non ça marche ça
marche ça nous allait enfin ça bouge à
peine la crème était prévue elle pour
elle fini de prendre le goût le goût des
carcasses et à dire vrai dire les
carcasses on a mis le fonds le fonds
était fait en même temps que les
volailles le bouquet garni on a tous
laissés dedans envoyer tes pas la peine
de faire réduire parce que finalement ça
a bien réduit et là maintenant à
l'inversé doucement les jaunes dans
cette crème aller doucement ma la
berceuse y allait être le coup et moi je
m'en vais faire lier sa co montpellier
une crème anglaise est normalement la
fusionnement la loi paille avant la
touche à renvoyer votre sauce là l
ailier très très doux fait attention de
plus à bouillir et à ce moment là vous
passez le tout sur la volaille avec un
petit ami comme ça et là vous appuyez
bien pour que tout passe dedans c'est à
dire tous le sucre des viandes tout ça
ça sedan et donc vous voyez votre poulet
à la crème il est fini alors rapide ans
a amassé 25 minutes 25 minutes de
cuisson
on a donc vous avez bonne volaille tu es
là on va la mettre sur le plateau là et
vous pouvez servir leur envoyer vous
avez une volaille qui est un rob et
rhymes et qui est juste assez assez
d'argent pour laisser mijoter un petit
peu à la crème comme ça mais par trop
pour plus de ça chauffe pas d'impôts
plus que ça bout pour la bonne raison
que c'est lié au jaune d'oeuf avec une
fois qu'il ya le journe si oui alors une
fois qu'ils finissent dans la crème
supporte très bien oui oui vous pouvez
ou de la crème alors vraiment là le
petit poireaux pommes la volaille à la
crème a lancé me dire qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire comme légume avec ça et bien
pour moi le meilleur légumes c'est de
faire un épinards en branche mais si on
apporte d'epinal en branche
on peut faire un riz on peut même faire
des petits pois parce qu'un petit pois
mélanger avec la crème des merveilles on
peut faire un rique au vert et puis vous
savez que comme dessert on a les pommes
ce qu'on appelle les paumes bonnes
femmes les pommes cuites au four c'est à
dire des pommes qu'ils ont mis dans un
plat les unes à côté des autres paires
c'est au milieu vous red bear du sucre
du suc toujours cristallisé parce que le
sucre i series et d'une bon goût et
croque le tout arrosé de vin blanc
mais dans le fourreau 25 minutes bien
arrosée et je vous souhaite un bon
appétit
quand merci zone est déjà verticale
botul
[Musique]